bismillah alhamdulillah assalamu alaikum
peace be with you thank you for tuning
in to the d show now we know that half
of your Deen this way of life that the
Creator sent through all the messengers
submission to the Creator not the
creation Islam is half of your faith is
marriage then you get married and you
have the little ones boys and girls but
how do you raise them Islam hasn't even
left you alone on that it's a complete
package from A to Z everything there we
have the blueprint the Quran and Sunnah
and we got somebody qualified enough in
the D show studio to give us some great
tips on how to raise some great kids so
they can be a benefit to society when we
come back here on the Deen show
this is the and welcome back to the D
show saw Michael share Holly from salon
what I hunted la Omar dr. Shaheen how
are you fine thank you
so just for our viewing audience to know
a little bit about you you're the
president of the North American Imams
Federation's that right yes he told him
about this organization North American
Imams Federation it's an organization
established in 2003 and it's concerned
about Imams we try our best to update
events to make him a more qualified and
to provide Islamic centers in need forum
and qualified demands we're trying our
best also to teach a man how for example
foreign Imams how to speak English how
to communicate with their community how
to use technology and all of these
things and you're also the director of
Islamic Studies at the GT GT a PDF yes
and that's where that's how we know each
other because we have dr. Sabeel imam
moussa and myself we're in your program
so i can you tell us a little bit it's
my honor that that you are in our
program and ph.d program actually grad
methodological foundation it's it's not
an Islamic institution but it we have
Department stomach studies Department
and I am the director of this department
and alhamdulillah we have almost about
200 students in our program we grant
bachelor degree master and PhD as well
masha'Allah we're honored to have you on
the program the topic raising kids a lot
of times it's easy to have them but now
it's a great responsibility I'll bring
them the right way so where do we start
I know it's a short amount of time that
we have so we want to get some good tips
and tricks so people can raise a good
healthy fast
first of all after praising allah
subhanaw taala peace be upon his servant
and last messenger prophet muhammad
sallallaahu listen what i want to say
that we as muslims community we need now
to read and understand the hadith of the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him in
details and in deep and there's
understanding because as Muslims we
count in two main resource of Sharia
Quran and Sunna and Sunna it is its
allah subhanaw taala
told us that in who allah wa hontou
panel hala in Halawa who know so we need
to believe that every word he said it's
a Lala Salama it there is a purpose for
each and every single word he said
because otherwise it won't be approved
by almighty allah subhanaw taala so we
need to start understand deeply the
hadith of the Prophet Muhammad SAW Allah
Allah I'll give you an example many
hadith we redid the origin a man came to
the prophet sallallaahu seller and these
start explaining the hadith after what
the prophets Allah Los Alamitos I
believe that no we should understand it
and read from the first word they are a
jewel a man came to the prophet
salaallah Selim
this is give us a hint that a man which
means he is not known to the companions
otherwise they will mention his name so
we need to know that this is teach us
one important thing in our life that the
prophets allah wa sallam as a leader as
a qualified leader he his all his door
is open for everyone whether he knows
him or he didn't
he doesn't know him and this is give us
the leader qualification so what I want
to say that we need to understand and
read the prophets allah wa sallam hadith
different than before we when we talk
about children there is just I will talk
about explain one hadith narrated by
even a bird
Allah be pleased with him and his father
as well and it gives us the methodology
of raising up and teaching children in
Islam one hat is only the prophet
sallallaahu Selim once he was riding
donkey and even at best may Allah be
pleased with him narrated about this
hadith he said couldn't toward even
maybe you saw mama very seldom at AHIMA
I was riding a donkey behind the Prophet
Muhammad SAW Allah Allah said let's stop
here and first talk about even our best
when he said I was behind the prophet
sallallaahu which mean he was a shy
little child otherwise they could not
could not both of them ride a donkey so
that means also told us that the prophet
mohammed salameh salaam while he was
walking riding his donkey he agreed a
little child so greeting children this
is the first step building and bridges
between you and the children which is
very important in raising of children in
Islam so we need to communicate with
children we should not ignore children
so the Prophet SAW Allah Selim he was
riding his donkey he noticed that it's
been at best a little child standing
there he greet him and asking him how
you doing how was everything
then he get the end he knows that he is
was going to somewhere so he offered him
a ride so first point we should not
ignore our children no matter how their
age so that's the first point that now
we covered that's very important
communication not shutting the lines of
communication Sheikh holder to tell us
we have to go to break
don't lose your place we got a lot more
to cover and ask you here on the Deen
show with dr. Sheikh Omar Shaheen when
we come back
they worship Jesus no you don't worship
Jesus we worship the cartilages you
thought you were shipped the God of
Jesus the one who Jesus fell on his face
and prayed to that's when we worship now
do we only believe in Mohammed no we
believe in all the prophets - starting
from the first man created
I'm Adam to Abraham look their son Jacob
and the tribe Moses and Jesus the last
pup was only homeless or some people so
we believe in all those messengers you
mentioned who you mentioned and there's
many more so we believe in all of them
all of them all the ones that are
mentioned in the Quran and other than
the the album day you know you don't
want September you what you worship
Allah who's a crater but it's part of
the belief to believe in these messages
yes your name like Jesus want to leave
it done well you don't worship them
don't worship them back here on the D
show and we're discussing the proper way
giving some tips and tricks to raise
some good children and before we went to
break you talking about healthy
communication not cutting off the doors
of communication with your children
please continue on yes this is very
important in our life because the minute
we closed the communications avenues
between us and our children that's the
end of it that's the end of it listen
and let's emphasize on the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him life the
children used to raised whom will shake
his hand first while he is in the street
the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
once he was walking with his companion
and he noticed that there is a little
child crying in the street he left he
excused himself from his companion and
he went to this little child can you
imagine the leader of the Ummah Allah is
messenger he excused himself from great
companions and he went to check the cry
why this little child is crying then he
asked why you are crying and he told him
that he has a little bird and run away
from its runs away runs away from him so
the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
listen open your heart for this advice
he told him yes Abajo mayor Madison
annual or father of all mayor what the
little bird have done to you
first of all he
communicate with him he gave attention
to his request and to his complain to
what he wants number two he called him
via about my while he was a little child
he built his personality he show him
respect and he give him the first step
of solving his a problem because this
little bird run away from so he built
his person at by telling him or calling
him Oh father
oh my ear so we need to build our
children personality by calling them
good big names show them respect never
ignored him that's the way we should
treat our children that's the way the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him used
to treat children can we imagine that
the prophets allah wa sallam while he
was sitting with his companion teaching
them their religion the most important
job in his life in our life a little
gear came to him pulling him from his
hand Salama Selim the Companions do you
want to discipline here what you are
doing but Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him listen to her and what you want she
pulled him him from his hand out to the
Masjid can you imagine what she want
yes she lost her toy and she won the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him to
search for it and he did so Lala listen
until he found it saw her smiling face
again he came back to his company that's
what we do with our children all respect
them to you may be what your child is
asking you is a silly thing not
important because his brother beat him
he say bad word about him to you it's
silly things but to him it's a very
important case in his life so we need to
give more attention to our children's
problems
complains and requests everything and
make it a big deal because otherwise
they after day year after year if you
are ignoring their complaints a day will
come when they could not or when they
are not coming to you for any problems
they have and that time you are going to
lose your children so communication
communication communication respect
build their personality yahoo lamb or
young man or yeah about all mayor he
used to call him with big names to show
them that you are something respect we
respect don't give them a small little
names because that will affect their
personality day after day and never
ignore their requests
never ignore their purse their personal
problems because it might be silly in
the first of their first 2 3 5 10 years
but after that they will when they start
having serious problem they won't come
to you if you ignore them before that's
what I want to advise myself first and
every teacher all parents to take care
of their children masha'Allah this is
great advice before we go to break tell
us now addressing their issues how would
you in a real situation now that the
person doesn't just have one two three
maybe they have four or five six kids
and you know young kids at the age of
four five three two four five six and
they're at each other's throats every
time they're you know fighting each
other hitting each other so how do you
deal with them disciplining them in a
healthy way
communicating with them and you know not
driving yourself mad at the same time
absolutely yes we might have four or
five children as you said and sometimes
our busy schedule will not allow us to
do such things with our children but we
as Muslims we need to learn priority
there is priority in our life absolutely
taking care of yourself
southern is one of the most important
thing we should do in our life so we
need to learn how to organize our time
how to give time to our children and our
D in our Islam taught us to respect the
time in everything if you look at the
player we play on specific time our
prayer won't be acceptable if we bring
one minute before the time is there our
fasting we are not we are going to break
our fast just one time we could not
break it half a minute before we sunset
for example so our D in teaching us how
to respect time so when we organize our
time we will be able to give our
children time we will be able to to give
everything need our time the right time
and we are not going to ignore our
sudden so organize your time will give
you that time to take care of your
children we have a problem with the time
we need to respect the time more and
give everything and learn priority then
we will find a big time in our life or
our beloved children beautiful so so far
we got we're gonna go to break but we
covered empowering your children giving
them good you know encouragement
spending time with them and what was the
other one the other one organizing
organizing time yes okay we're going to
take a break and we right back to wrap
it up here on the Dean show why don't
you wanna
is he not worthy of praise and thanks I
mean think about all the blessings that
we have of the life he created you he's
the one that feeds you he's the one that
takes care of you the ability to see one
unbelievable blessing and
start fresh today a new page a new
beginning and reach out to the one who
created you ask him for guidance back
here on the Dean show will shake dr.
Umar Shaheen and we're discussing giving
us some great advice communication was
the first thing that you talked about
and expounding this all the wizard is
wisdom from this hadith is there any
more wisdom that we can get from the
study absolutely this hadith by the way
it's teach us the methodology of raising
children in Islam just one hadith
because the prophets Allah saw him he
was very wise and smart and he put every
word for a purpose anyway let's continue
the prophets allah wa sallam even I bet
even our best may Allah be pleased with
him riding behind him the first minute
he get there the Prophet SAW wasallam
start greeting him and talked to him
you haven't had best or yahoo lon o
young man let's go back take us back to
build their personality respect show
them respect young man in me allah mukha
climate i am going to teach you a few
words and we need to stop here for a
second he said a few words he did not
see lectures why because he is talking
to a child you need to give him few
words so he can understand so he can
have extra time for fun as a child so
the Prophet SAW Allah sallam he noticed
that he is talking to a child and he
told him in neo Halima Kelly mad oh this
is my advice to myself to teachers to
parents please don't be harsh in your
children give them the time to have fun
the prophets allah wa sallam he said in
new an American metal it's learned from
him so la la salem he said tell him a
few words not lectures not hours and
hour sitting down and teaching him again
and again in your Olympic element for
will have beautiful words beautiful
advice from him salam ala Salam
- this little child me I love you please
with him for the life take care of
Allah's command Allah will take care of
you and the prophets allah wa sallam did
not stop here he continued and he said
the same meaning with different words
because he acknowledged that he is
talking to a little child or to a child
so what he did Salah lisara he repeats
himself different words the same meaning
so the child if he missed the first
point he will get it from the second
statement and that's what we need to do
with our children repeat and repeat and
repeat if they did mistake once doesn't
mean that this is the end of the life
there are subjects to do mistakes like
we as a human beings adult or children
we do all the sticks
so one mistakes from your shot it
doesn't mean that's that this is the end
of the life two mistakes three mistakes
we need to be patient and repeat
ourselves once twice thrice as many as
they want until they understand what we
want to teach them then the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him when he start
talking about a father died I thought
take care of a lost man Allah will take
care of you
he started with the first step or the
first level of Islam which practicing
Islam take care of Allah's command
Allah command us to pray to fast to do
this to do that so he started with the
first level of Islam and we need to
acknowledge priority priorities is very
important in our life you could not
teach as a little child
something about computer while he could
not even understand what you are what
you are saying so we need to acknowledge
their age and teach them what they can
handle what they can understand
priorities is very important for the
layer [ __ ] every lie that you do to that
either
Lila beautiful if the stand toughest and
Billa
masha'allah the most beautiful hadith I
learned from him salabhasana if you ask
for help ask allah's help the same thing
he repeat himself again with the same
meaning different words because he is
talking to a child in the stunts of
Aston Villa if you ask for help ask
allah's help only he connect his heart
to almighty allah subhanaw taala this is
the second level of Dean Eman connect
your heart with the action we did in
Islam to almighty allah subhanho wa
taala then he said some la laa listen
what eylem animals tonight you need to
know even a bass violin which means you
are qualified to learn and this is again
building his personality never think or
give him the impression that you are a
little kid you don't understand what I'm
saying no prophets Allah sorry mrs.
violin you need to learn so you are
qualified to learn well I'm an alumna
you will need to learn even at best may
Allah be pleased with him that if the
whole human beings get together to
benefit you while a lot of the one they
want beautiful he want to confirm the
Eman he taught him in the second
statement with the third level the
highest level of Eman which is make sure
that know nothing in your heart but
Allah subhanAllah this is how we go
gradually step by step with our children
so we need to learn that communication
is very important thing with our
children never ignore them number two
build their personality show them
respect
never ignore their complains no matter
how little it is how silly it it is
number three we need to give them time
by how we give them the right time by
giving by organizing our time we are we
have a lot of things to take care of
but we need to give our beloved children
the most important of our time and but
when we organize our time after that we
need to teach them we need to teach our
self first priority then teach our
children priorities as well how to do
what to do when to do it's very
important in their children life so we
ask allah subhanaw taala to benefit also
from this is just a hints and tips how
we should understand the hadith of the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him first
second how to the and treat children
in Islam we ask allah subhanaw taala to
grant us the real understanding of our
faith I mean I mean and before we cut
out we're almost out of time all of this
from one hadith and this is not coming
from any top psychologist or any top
specialist in this area we got all this
from the last and final messenger
muhammad peace be upon him yes 101
hadith only this is this is the way by
the way I teach my children or my
students the hadith whether they are Bhd
or masters or even in 10th or 11th grade
I write the hadith in the board and I
start asking them what we understand
from the first world they are a jewel as
we said mentioned in the beginning a man
came what we understand and you start
masha'Allah we have a very smart
children with very smart students and
sometimes I learn learn from them more
than they learn from me this is a major
leave it or not thank you I wish we had
more time thank you so much me the
creator of the heavens and earth Allah
reward you for being such lovely well
yeah thank you so much so I'm like and
thank you for tuning in to the d show I
hope you got the benefit I surely did
and advice benefits to believer as the
crater tells us in the Quran and he sent
the Quran and the example the problem
Hamid peace be upon who was the brother
to Jesus Moses and all the preceding
messengers who came with the same
message worship the Creator not the
Christian do good prepare for the day of
judgment and what are you going to leave
behind in this life all the money all
the wealth all those things are going to
stay behind but a righteous child now
will elevate you in the next life
can doall for you praying to God for you
so make sure that we're raising children
to go ahead and be good servants to the
crater so they can live a good righteous
life and we can benefit from this and we
got to learn about communication
empowering our children and we weren't
getting this from no top psychologist
and so the kansai colleges will tell you
the same thing we're getting this from
the last and final messenger centers
mankind the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him so I'm gonna do my best to
implement these things I hope you are
too and tune in every week to the D
she'll follow us on the Twitter like us
on the Facebook help us spread this
message so more people can benefit from
this and they can live the purpose of
life they can have peace in their lives
and they can be successful in this life
and have paradise in the next we'll see
you next time God will until that peace
be with you